this is our second viewing second for me
is this your second yeah yeah I shot it
yeah high school is when I saw this
movie uh I didn't like it but but you
got this
I guess not huge but big enough
following where it's kind of game to say
it's like it's the underground dark
Disney film of which there surprisingly
a lot when you think about like return
to the film that gave Jeffrey Katzenberg
a heart attack
this was supposed to be like a Pirates
of the Caribbean
became where it's like this was kind of
the darker edgier PG movie you know
we're gonna go a rating above what we
usually do and it lost to the Care Bears
movie like big like it was said to be
the saddest day in Disney history a
major animated Disney film loss to a
greeting card you can vouch for the fact
we actually saw that one as kids you
just their promos everywhere and then it
just vanished that's right weird they
must have like pulled it after a week
like it was like but it's so dark cool
it's still annoying
it still has really annoying main
character yeah I'm already dreading
hearing that voices so here we go second
viewing haven't seen this in years of a
Black Cauldron maybe a bit better than I
remember let's check it out
I love that logo logo tucks in my heart
I love that logo comb we need a minute
alone
yes there was once a king so cruel and
so even scat aw man that is so weird
it's just that old eighties that
old-school animation yeah it countless
like this story but those golden story
books though doesn't it'll bit if this
was a Don Bluth movie he's a baguette
it's so weird like cuz this movie to me
feels like well it was introduction
forever but it feels like it was made in
like 1975 yeah
it has that and I kind of like that look
it's a look I kind of enjoy this is the
Black Cauldron cooking sous
anti-climactic no wonder the pours
always came out with living skulls and
zombies I do remember it strangely
thinking the pig probably had the most
personality in the movie
I'm a warrior not a pig keeper I want
more but you might just punch the
out of this kid don't you want to like
give them a million wedgie
anti it's called the hero's journey that
likable well neither was Luke Skywalker
but Star Wars still managed I pulled up
but that had Star Wars on top of Luke
Skywalker - what we need are a few Thai
fighters in this an old fist that's it
looks as though I'll still be an
assistant pinkie but when I'm as old as
good that's all she talks about
I'm no hero and I wouldn't be a here man
I want to be such a whiner
so full of hate for this movie oh yeah
this weird this is the weirdest I
like weird no but this isn't like
whimsical this is just odd this looks
like something a drunk guy comes up with
no no the pig gets these visions you got
slam or face and water and there spits
shows visions of the future and evil
it's like how they did back in the
Middle Ages they slammed pigs faces and
water and it's puke predicted the future
yes about that we're gonna be scrying
where you would take like a bone like
the shoulder bone of like beef or
something and basically Achon and in
order to divine the future people did
weird it's the Horned King to find
it then middle of Asia land will be his
middle Fantasia's I will say this the
last time I saw this was on VHS it is
really nice
to see a digital copies
honestly I need like this soundtrack
album you have it it's got so much
reflection in the water like this I'm
listening to what a five years please
animations nice but I sees a little way
yeah a little bit oh man he came in this
early oh now we have these two
throughout the majority of the film and
she's so excited now Rob he's gonna star
in the straight story and it's gonna be
wonderful
Donald Duck got his desperate giving his
last will and testament to Huey Dewey
and Louie it really does have that vibe
of like George Lucas saw this it was
like I have an idea for the prequels you
know Clark if he starts humping your leg
just boy ya dance why abandon quest for
Camelot saw this and said just make it a
girl well amazing I'm awesome
just making a girl and they suck all of
the cool crap out of it are you coming I
could use bait and lunch if you look at
everything behind the main characters
it's a good movie whoa bud what's have
been back from the Great Mouse Detective
structure to show me whereabouts of the
black also I wish to see blackish hey
funny tell her to put that out after the
black hole I got a theme going tonight
it's black isn't that also what they
called him in deliverance
hi I'm Zola I'm here to rescue a link
let's really be honest in her hair was
on him you could not tell them apart
like the exact same fake aladdin and
Jasmine heck had the same thing like
they drew him a little too similar
those backgrounds are cool they aren't
really cool must've been a great warrior
here lies Carrie the Cowardly he was a
terrible warrior
Oh a stand corrected this sword was
never used once he accidentally fell on
it thus giving hints and I'll give you a
new dye pack you mean well he's not
going to use it but it's still got his
hand attached it's good luck least I
don't keep talking about it forever oh
you're so bored I'm so boring that's the
best insult she could come up with is
this really cry worthy without you
actually I probably could have liked if
the sword was in my hands pretty much do
the same thing totally like they were
cobbled together from other lesser
Fantasy browser like Fern Gully Fern
Gully
I'm seeing a lot of like some David the
gnome some Smurfs like a rock you just
cut back to them and there's like magic
mushrooms like they're like haha
they've gone nowhere they're just right
by that pond you know reminds me of a
little bit but there's a little bit more
leeway for this it might be they have
Aragon just going from one every fantasy
thing to another every fantasy thing but
this is a little older so it has a
little bit more leeway apparently like
this is it's like a series clicking
deaths of five plugs down to one and so
they entered the swamp of despair
they're the pig got depressed and
started drowning boy that villain from
the rescuers really let herself go we
find out these originally the female
squirrels from sort of the stove and
turn the back yeah
they're very blue thean yeah I love the
way they move all right
they turned into a I do I'll give it
that I've never seen that it still works
down there don't try to make me cry yeah
no that's all yeah yeah oh no not him
cuz you're Simon Belmont I don't get
what they are now what is that I just
don't they get the sword and now they're
farts I don't understand us a bunch of
shady bitches to have this cauldron of
resurrecting the undead for that little
face furball our is in the script
another he's still dead amazing I love
this movie investigate at least we know
we're eating tonight I won't start a
fire I'll skin him
[Music]
it's not as bad as I remember I wouldn't
call it a great Disney movie but I like
just how bad is the weird but it's
not crazy it's gray but it's not part
are the weakest part is the heroes yeah
the story in general it's just a very
basic fancy story very basic fantasy
characters and and they're kind of
Italian yeah I like her early on when
she's like taking initiative and then
they just turn her into Karl like issues
becomes like rob princess yeah if
somebody likes it I totally get it I
understand it for dark kid stuff but are
you defending it's like no this is good
this is the underrated how could anyone
not see the brilliance of this movie
like that I'm not getting
brilliant spots in this movie you can't
argue it's not a mess like you even if
you love this movie you have to like
look at this like from a narrative
standpoint and everything be like okay
this is messy you can just tell
something was off that's about it I bet
you're very curious what kind of review
I get out of it because there's a lot to
talk about it like what angle do you
take so that'd be fun to figure out so
that's about it and um
peak I just go out on the dark the dark
movie let's go out that Detective what
did he mean by pink so we know to go out
of those weird movies
you